.
* Martinshorn *
Er ist seit 17 Jahren Polizist.
* Klopfen *
Polizei.
Sie beginnen gerade
mit ihrer Ausbildung.
Frau Stierli,
Ihre persönliche Dienstwaffe.
Eine Wahnsinnsverantwortung.
Die Routine fehlt.
Wenn du dich unwohl fühlst,
kannst du die Dienstwaffe ziehen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Montag, kurz nach 22 Uhr.
Nach einem pädophilen Übergriff
soll Yves Chappuis helfen,
den mutmasslichen Täter zu verhaften,
damit er keine Beweismittel ver-
schwinden lassen oder fliehen kann.
Vor dem Zugriff: ein Briefing
mit dem Kollegen der Kriminalpolizei.
Der Täter wurde offenbar
mit dem Geschehenen konfrontiert.
Die Staatsanwalt hat verfügt,
dass er sofort geholt werden muss.
Deshalb diese Feuerwehrübung.
Pasci kommt.
Ich wäre froh,
wenn ihr mich unterstützen könntet
bei der Aussensicherung.
Dann schauen wir.
Wir gehen rauf und sprechen ihn an.
Wir checken die Situation ab.
Und wir geben euch
so bald wie möglich wieder frei.
Noch kurz ein Bild davon.
Wenn es wider Erwarten ...- (Frau)
Ging der nicht gerade vorbei?
Echt?
- Der sah sehr ähnlich aus.
Ich achtete nicht darauf.
- Ich auch nicht.
Dort rechts, ist er das?
- Ja.
Offenbar spricht er mit jemandem,
der in einem Auto mit laufendem Motor
sitzt.
Guten Abend.
Ja, ein Ausweis wäre sehr gut.
Der Ausweis bestätigt:
Es ist der Gesuchte.
Cyril, kannst du
nach hinten zu uns fahren?
Dann können wir
direkt hier weitermachen.
Gut, danke. Tschüss.
Das war ein Glückstreffer.
Die Kriminalpolizisten kommen.
Sie wollen
den Verdächtigen direkt mitnehmen
und mit der Hausdurchsuchung
beginnen.
Yves Chappuis soll klären,
wer der Mann im Auto ist.
Wir würden euch
sonst Bescheid geben.
Macht ihr kurz euer Business fertig.
Dann melden wir uns wieder.
Ein Bekannter des Verdächtigen.
Er scheint mit dem Fall
nichts zu tun zu haben.
Sie dürfen weiterfahren.
Seine Personalien
wurden aufgenommen.
Weiter zur Hausdurchsuchung.
Ein Blick in die Küche,
wo der Verdächtige sitzt,
bewacht von einem Polizisten.
Yves Chappuis
ist Vater zweier Jungen,
die ähnlich alt sind
wie das mutmassliche Opfer.
Ich komme gut damit klar.
Ich entwickle
keinen persönlichen Hass.
Zumal ich nicht weiss,
was alles passiert ist.
Bis alles geklärt ist,
gilt die Unschuldsvermutung.
Ach du Scheisse.
Der mutmassliche Täter lebt alleine.
Er hat beruflich
mit Jugendlichen zu tun.
Den nehmen wir sicher mit.
USB-Stick.
Die ganze Wohnung
wird akribisch durchsucht.
Diverse potenzielle Beweismittel
werden sichergestellt.
Bei einer Hausdurchsuchung
liegt das Augenmerk
auf verdächtigen Gegenständen
im Zusammenhang mit dem Fall.
Wir haben klare Vorstellungen davon,
was wir suchen.
Bisher haben wir einiges gefunden.
Klar, man schaut alles an.
In der Wäsche kann auch z.B.
ein Speichermedium versteckt sein.
Deshalb wird das alles
grob durchgeschaut.
Eine Riesenarbeit -
aber es lohnt sich.
In diesem Fall
ist alles von speziellem Interesse,
worauf sich einschlägige Bilder
oder Videos befinden könnten.
Wie viel?
2 GB.
MP3, WMA.
Sogar in Kugelschreibern
hat er Speicherkarten versteckt.
Sie ist vorne angemalt.
- Echt?
Und es steckt eine SD-Karte drin?
8 GB, aber das geht wohl noch höher.
Das letzte Mal an einer Schulung
gesehen. Noch nie live.
Aber es gibt es wirklich.
Die Wohnung wirkt verwahrlost.
Ich bin eher ein reinlicher Mensch.
Wenn ich so etwas sehe,
ekelt es mich.
Und die Augen brennen
nach 1,5 Std. Sachen durchwühlen.
Später
werden Spezialisten untersuchen,
ob sich tatsächlich irgendwo ein-
schlägige Bilder oder Videos finden.
Nach der Hausdurchsuchung wird
der mutmassliche Täter mitgenommen
und ins Gefängnis gebracht.
Mit Handschellen?
- Ja.
Vorne sicher.
Er war relativ anständig.
- Ich würde trotzdem ...
Lieber noch mal genau nachlesen,
damit keine Fehler passieren.
"Der Beschuldigte
muss im Gefängnis
einer Leibesvisitation
unterzogen werden."
Ich habe das erst einmal gemacht.
Mein Kollege, der dabei war,
kannte sich damit aus.
Für Yves Chappuis
ist der Fall erledigt,
sobald der Mann im Gefängnis ist.
Dann übernehmen Kriminalpolizei
und Staatsanwaltschaft.
Sie gehören ebenfalls
zum Polizeikorps Basel-Landschaft -
allerdings erst seit heute.
Vier Männer und zwei Frauen
haben ihren ersten Tag.
Auf dem Ausweis
steht unten eine Nummer.
Diese Nummer müssen Sie überprüfen -
es handelt sich
um Ihre Personalnummer.
Diese Personalnummer begleitet Sie
während der nächsten 35 Jahren.
* Lachen *
Herr Wüthrich.
Ihr Ausweis.
Und Frau Stierli.
Sie wurden in einem
aufwendigen Selektionsverfahren
auf Herz und Nieren geprüft
und haben es schliesslich geschafft.
Ich begrüsse Sie ganz herzlich.
Mein Name ist Mark Burkhard,
ich bin Kommandant
der Polizei Basel-Landschaft.
Ich freue mich sehr,
dass Sie hier sind.
Wir sind
dringend auf Nachwuchs angewiesen.
Es ist nicht ganz einfach,
genügend guten Nachwuchs zu finden.
Wir wollen das Niveau
der Polizeiausbildung nicht senken.
Entsprechend ist es schwierig,
genügend gute Leute zu finden.
Darum haben wir sehr grosses Inte-
resse daran, Sie zu unterstützen.
Ich möchte gerne
eine Vorstellungsrunde machen,
da es mich sehr interessiert,
wer Sie sind. Möchten Sie beginnen?
Mein Name ist Nando Wüthrich, 24,
komme aus Blauen.
Nun wohne ich in Laufen.
Ich absolvierte das KV E-Profil
und arbeitete dann
ein Jahr als Buchhalter.
Danach absolvierte
ich den Militärdienst.
Anschliessend arbeitete ich
ein Jahr lang als Zeitmilitarist.
Danach kehrte ich in die Privatwirt-
schaft zurück, ins Eventmanagement,
wo ich während der letzten
eineinhalb Jahre tätig war.
Heute bin ich hier,
um einen neuen Weg einzuschlagen.
Meine Hobbys: Velofahren, Joggen,
ausserdem
bin ich in einer Guggenmusik
und seit vielen Jahren
in der Pfadi in Laufen.
Gut. Frau Stierli?
Ich bin gelernte Fachfrau Gesundheit
und diplomierte Pflegefachfrau.
Letztere Ausbildung
schloss ich vor zwei Wochen ab.
In der Freizeit
begleitet mich der Sport.
Ich bin im Boxen unterwegs,
auf dem Bike, ich wandere.
Und nebenbei spiele ich Klavier.
Gut. Viel Spass am ersten Tag.
Machen Sie's gut.
Bis bald.
Ein selbst produzierter Imagefilm
soll der Bevölkerung
einen Einblick geben
in die Arbeit
der Polizei Basel-Landschaft
und potenziellen Nachwuchs
für den Beruf interessieren.
Es bewerben sich viele,
aber nur wenige bringen
die nötigen Qualifikationen mit,
um Polizistin oder Polizist
zu werden.
Darum
haben viele Korps Nachwuchsprobleme.
Es gibt andere Firmen, die auch
interessante Tätigkeiten anbieten.
Entsprechend befinden wir uns
in einer Konkurrenzsituation.
Medienberichten kann man entnehmen,
dass der Beruf anspruchsvoll ist.
Z.B., wenn es Gewalt und Drohungen
gegen Polizeibeamte gibt.
Oder wenn bei Grosseinsätzen
die Polizei kritisiert wird.
Das zeigt,
dass es nicht immer einfach ist.
Es gibt auch objektive Gründe dafür,
warum es Probleme
bei der Auswahl gibt.
Wenn es an der Sportlichkeit
scheitert oder am Deutsch.
Bei vielen jungen Personen ist
das schriftliche Deutsch mangelhaft.
Das ist ein wichtiger Teil
unserer Tätigkeit.
Deshalb ist die Auswahl beschränkt.
Der Nachwuchs wird eingekleidet,
für alle Wetter- und Gefahrenlagen.
Dieses Teil hier,
wie es im Moment da ist,
ist die Unterziehweste.
Da sind die Panels bereits drin.
So würden wir sie unter dem Hemd,
dem Poloshirt oder Pullover tragen.
Die Ausrüstung macht deutlich: Der
Polizeiberuf kann gefährlich sein.
Respekt, sicher.
Aber ich denke,
wie sich das auf mich auswirkt,
wird sich in der Ausbildung zeigen.
Und auch, welche Situationen kommen
und wie man reagieren muss.
Ich freue mich darauf,
das zu lernen,
damit diese Unsicherheit
und der Respekt etwas abnehmen.
Angst ...
Nicht direkt.
Ich habe eine solche Situation
noch nie erlebt.
Ich habe den Beruf bisher
nur von aussen gesehen,
ich habe noch nie darauf gearbeitet.
Das wird sich
in den nächsten Monaten zeigen.
Alle bekommen am ersten Tag
ihre persönliche Dienstwaffe.
Was dürfen Sie
mit dieser Pistole machen?
Sie dürfen sich
in Notwehr verteidigen.
Sie dürfen,
wenn jemand angegriffen wird,
Notwehrhilfe leisten.
Und Sie dürfen sie einsetzen
zur Erfüllung
ihrer polizeilichen Aufgaben,
wenn Menschen
an Leib und Leben bedroht sind.
Vizekommandant, Aspirant Wüthrich,
bereit zur Waffenübergabe.
Herr Wüthrich,
Ihre persönliche Dienstwaffe.
Danke.
Vizekommandant, Aspirantin Stierli,
bereit zur Waffenübergabe.
Frau Stierli,
Ihre persönliche Dienstwaffe.
Danke.
Einerseits kenne ich es bereits
aus dem Militärdienst.
Andererseits ist immer
ein gewisser Grundrespekt vorhanden
gegenüber dieser Waffe
bzw. diesem System,
da man weiss, wozu es existiert
und wozu es eingesetzt werden kann.
Eine Waffe zu bekommen
ist ein sehr besonderes Gefühl.
Das bedeutet
eine Wahnsinnsverantwortung.
Ich empfinde
auch einen gewissen Stolz,
dass ich sie bekommen durfte.
Ja.
Yves Chappuis
weiss bei keinem Einsatz,
was er vor Ort genau antrifft.
Er muss immer
vom Schlimmsten ausgehen,
auch wenn das
nur selten eintrifft.
Auch jetzt:
Eine Frau
hat Alarm geschlagen.
Seit zwei Tagen kein Lebenszeichen
ihres Nachbarn.
Normalerweise
seien sie täglich in Kontakt.
Den Briefkasten
habe er nicht mehr geleert,
die Storen seien unten.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe etwas gehört.
Hier ist die Polizei.
Josi ist hier.
Es hört sich an,
als könnte er sich nicht bewegen.
Ich glaube, er kann sich nicht
bewegen. Er spricht deutlich.
Der Schlüssel steckt von innen.
Moment.
Kannst du nicht zur Tür kommen?
Wo bist du?
Können Sie mir zeigen,
wo die Terrasse ist? - Hinten.
Ich bleibe hier.
Eingeschlossen. Er liegt
blutverschmiert auf dem Boden.
Hier komme ich nicht rein,
der Schlüssel steckt von innen.
Wie kommen wir rein? Durch den
Haupteingang mit Schlüsseldienst?
Oder kann man bei dir öffnen?
Eine ungewohnte Situation,
dass wir zu Einbrechern werden.
Aber in diesem Fall
ist es nötig.
Ist da Platz für uns beide?
Uff.
- Jetzt ist offen.
Hallo?
- Hallo?
Polizei.
Der Krankenwagen ist unterwegs.
Was ist passiert?
- (Mann) Ich weiss es nicht.
Sie sind wohl gestürzt.
Das war ...
... höchste Zeit.
Hallo zusammen. Tschau, hoi.
(Mann) Haben Sie sich
den Kopf gestossen?
Warte.
Hast du die Beine?
- Ja. Gut.
(Mann) Gut, habt ihr?
- Ja.
Dann etwas runter.
- Ich bin oben.
Lassen wir ihn gleich hier drauf.
Wegen solcher Momente
ist Yves Chappuis Polizist geworden.
Die Grundhaltung ist,
den Menschen helfen zu wollen,
sie im Alltag zu unterstützen.
Wenn ich mit Menschen zu tun habe,
ist mir wichtig,
ihre Geschichte ernst zu nehmen,
ihnen zuzuhören,
um zu verstehen,
was ihnen wichtig ist.
Ich versuche das Möglichste,
damit der Fall gut läuft.
Zeit für eine kurze Pause
zum Durchatmen.
Yves Chappuis und sein Kollege gril-
lieren im Garten des Polizeipostens.
Er machte eine Lehre
als Landmaschinenmechaniker
und hatte nach der RS eine neue Idee:
Polizist werden.
Wenn ich damals gewusst hätte,
wie es heute draussen läuft,
hätte ich es mir zweimal überlegt,
das zu machen.
Es ist doch ziemlich belastend,
v.a. die unregelmässigen
Arbeitszeiten.
Mal früh, mal Nacht, dann mittel,
dann wieder Schalter.
Das belastet schon.
Man ist nicht immer ausgeruht genug.
Die Laune ist
entsprechend z.T. etwas verändert.
Nicht das Erlebte
macht ihm also zu schaffen.
V.a. die unregelmässigen Arbeits-
zeiten belasten ihn und sein Umfeld.
Verstanden, wir fahren.
Ein Einbruch in einem Hotel.
(Funk) BS-1203 von Zentrale,
antworten.
Ja, verstanden, zur Kenntnis:
Wir sind in Therwil,
unterwegs Mariastein, Einbruchalarm.
Vorne, das mit den Schirmen.
Genau.
- Mit dem Warteck-Zeichen.
Wo gehst du?
- Links durch.
Ich rechts.
Gut.
Da ist auch geschlossen.
Als erste Patrouille
umstellt man das Objekt.
Man sichert die Eckpunkte.
Dann gehst du alleine
nach hinten ins Dunkle.
Du weisst nicht, was dich erwartet.
Kann sein, dass jemand gerade
zum Fenster heraussteigt.
Dann ... würde es hektisch.
Wenn du dich unwohl fühlst,
kannst du die Dienstwaffe ziehen
und in Bereitschaft gehen.
So bist du sicher bereit.
Gezogen hat er seine Waffe schon oft,
geschossen noch nie.
Keine Spur vom Einbrecher.
Das Luzerner Seetal: Hier lassen
die Polizei Basel-Landschaft
und zehn weitere Kantone
der Zentral- und Nordwestschweiz
ihren Nachwuchs ausbilden.
Seit 2006 ist hier in Hitzkirch
die Interkantonale Polizeischule.
Im ehemaligen Lehrerseminar Hitzkirch
und auf dem Gelände des früheren Zi-
vilschutzausbildungszentrums Aabach.
Rund 250 angehende Polizisten
werden hier jedes Jahr ausgebildet.
Alle sechs Monate
beginnt ein neuer Lehrgang.
Heute dabei: Jana Stierli
und Nando Wüthrich aus dem Baselbiet.
Schon etwas nervös, aufgeregt
wegen dem, was uns alles erwartet
in den kommenden Stunden.
Das wird gut.
Der frühe Morgen in Hitzkirch
beginnt mit einer Aufgabe.
Wir müssen
unseren persönlichen Spind finden,
mit unserer Nummer,
die wir auswendig gelernt haben.
Ja ... Sollen wir?
Alles ist neu - nicht nur die vielen
Gesichter aus anderen Kantonen.
Jana Stierli versucht,
sich einen Überblick zu verschaffen.
Jetzt habe ich ihn gefunden.
Die Grundausbildung
dauert zwei Jahre.
Das erste Jahr
absolvieren sie in Hitzkirch.
Im zweiten Jahr wenden sie das
Gelernte in ihrem Korps praktisch an
und schliessen die Ausbildung
mit der eidg. Berufsprüfung ab.
Der Anfang eines neuen
Lebensabschnittes für Jana Stierli:
vom Gesundheitswesen zur Polizei.
Es ist eine ganz andere
Herausforderung bei der Polizei.
Ausser der Sozialkontakt
zu den Menschen, der bleibt gleich.
Polizisten lösen Emotionen aus -
auch negative.
Man muss damit umgehen können, dass
man nicht bei allen beliebt ist.
Wie ich es wahrnehme,
wird aber die Polizei vom grössten
Teil der Gesellschaft akzeptiert
und als notwendig angesehen.
Für einige werden sie
durch ihre Uniform zu Reizfiguren,
für andere zu Hoffnungsträgern.
Ein stolzes Bild mit 138 Personen,
die heute, am 8. Oktober,
ihre Ausbildung in Hitzkirch
beginnen.
Herzlich willkommen,
liebe Aspirantinnen und Aspiranten,
zu eurem ersten Ausbildungstag.
Der Nachwuchs
soll dafür sensibilisiert werden,
dass er ab heute
unter Beobachtung steht.
Aus Zivilisten werden Polizisten.
Diese sollen Vorbilder sein.
Und sie sollen sich wesensmässig
transformieren:
Aus diesen jungen Menschen
wolle man Wölfe machen,
sagt der Leiter der Grundausbildung.
Was ist das Gegenteil des Wolfs?
Zumindest in der Schweiz?
(Frau) Das Schaf.
- Das Schaf.
Sollten noch Schafe
unter Ihnen sein,
müssen wir
schnellstmöglich dafür sorgen,
dass Wölfe daraus werden.
Der Wolf
hat viele Eigenschaften,
die Polizist/-innen
auch mitbringen sollten.
Man trifft sie auch an bei uns:
Er kommt im Rudel daher,
man steht füreinander ein,
es gibt soziale Gefüge.
Es gibt
eine stark ausgeprägte Hierarchie.
Unsere Leute sollen das lernen
und sich entsprechend verhalten.
Jana Stierli wusste schon als Kind,
dass sie zur Polizei wollte.
Zwei ihrer Onkel mütterlicherseits
sind Polizisten,
einer davon ist ihr Patenonkel.
Das hat mich inspiriert
und mich davon überzeugt,
dass ich Polizistin werden will.
Es ist viel mehr
als ein einziger Beruf,
es steckt so viel im Polizeiberuf.
Deshalb wusste ich schon immer,
dass ich Polizistin werden will.
* Sie lacht. *
Die Aufnahmeprüfung
schaffte sie problemlos.
Die Vorfreude
auf ihren neuen Beruf ist riesig.
Jawohl, schön. Hopp, hopp, hopp.
Jawohl, super gemacht.
Der besondere Reiz ist, dass man
bei Arbeitsbeginn nie weiss,
was einen erwartet,
welche Situationen
und welche Erlebnisse
man am Feierabend mitnimmt.
Das macht die Faszination aus.
Und in extrem schwierigen
Situationen
einen kühlen Kopf zu bewahren,
die Emotionen ablegen zu können
in schwierigen Situationen.
Auch Nando Wüthrich
ist sozusagen genetisch vorbelastet
in Sachen Polizeiberuf.
Sein Vater arbeitet
bei der Kantonspolizei Basel-Stadt.
Im Militär profilierte er sich
als Führungspersönlichkeit
und brachte es
bis zum Kompaniekommandanten.
Jetzt macht er sich fit
für den Polizeidienst.
Hm.
Ich trieb schon immer viel Sport,
aber seit ich bei der Polizei bin,
mache ich definitiv mehr Sport -
mehr Ausdauersport.
Es ist eine andere Motivation,
deshalb mache ich mehr.
Da ich weiss, wofür ich trainiere.
Und ich weiss auch,
dass es mir etwas bringt,
in den betreffenden Situationen
entsprechend bereit zu sein.
Für seinen Bubentraum
gibt er vollen Einsatz.
Auch Jana Stierli übt fleissig.
Unterstützt wird die 22-Jährige
von ihrer Mutter.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Stierli,
Polizei Basel-Landschaft.
Sie möchten Anzeige erstatten.
- Ja.
Worum geht es?
Mein Nachbar, Herr Muster,
hat mit seinem Auto an meinem Auto
einen Schaden verursacht.
Ich sah es zufälligerweise,
er streitet es aber ab.
Wie lauten Ihr Name
und Ihre Adresse?
Stierli Andrea.
Wollen Sie Strafantrag stellen
oder nicht?
Was heisst das?
Ein Strafantrag bedeutet,
dass wir ermitteln.
Sie können dann entscheiden,
ob Sie Strafklage erheben wollen,
dass der Nachbar also bestraft wird,
oder eine Zivilklage,
bei der Sie Schadenersatz bekommen
oder Genugtuung für den Schaden.
Sie können auch beides erheben.
Das passiert aber nur,
wenn Sie einen Strafantrag stellen.
Damit das weitergehen kann.
- Ja.
Gut. Vielen Dank. Auf Wiedersehen.
- Sehr gerne. Auf Wiedersehen.
Ich habe Respekt.
Ich habe Respekt davor,
was sie tut.
Auch weil sich die Gesellschaft
stark verändert hat.
Die Aggressionen gegen Menschen
in Uniform haben zugenommen,
finde ich.
Und dort ... habe ich Respekt
davor, was sie tut.
Diese Aggressionen
gegen Menschen in Uniform
zeigten sich vor der Coronapandemie
z.B. nach Fussballspielen.
Besonders explosiv waren jeweils
Begegnungen zwischen dem FC Basel
und Zürcher Klubs -
Hochrisikospiele.
Hallo. Tschau.
Yves Chappuis wurde regelmässig
zum sog. Ordnungsdienst eingeteilt.
Alle sind nervös.
Aber ich mache das
schon eine ganze Weile.
Man weiss sich auch zu helfen.
Es sind gute Kollegen dabei.
Von daher hält sich die Nervosität
in Grenzen.
Diese Bilder entstanden
anlässlich eines Hochrisikospiels,
entsprechend die Ausrüstung.
Das ist die Haftstrasse
in Arlesheim, im Schoren.
Hier unten im Keller
ist eine Anlage,
in der wir bei Grossereignissen
mehrere Personen
kurzzeitig festhalten können,
um weitere Abklärungen vorzunehmen.
Das Ziel sind
möglichst wenige Verhaftungen,
denn jede einzelne bedeutet Arbeit -
das braucht Ressourcen.
Was uns aber nicht davon abhalten
soll, jemanden mitzunehmen.
Leute, die eine Straftat begehen,
werden mitgenommen.
Eine kurze Besprechung
vor dem Einsatz.
Mit der Hitze haben wir heute
sicher auch zu kämpfen.
Wir haben die alten Taxis
ohne Klimaanlage.
Wir haben diesen Granatwerfer dabei.
Damit können wir
unterschiedliche Munition schiessen:
Gummi, Gas oder anderes.
Ich bin heute Schütze
auf unserem Taxi.
D.h., ich führe den Werfer mit mir.
Mein Kollege ist Hilfsschütze
und hat auch eine Packung Munition.
Die Polizei Basel-Landschaft unter-
stützt bei solchen Hochrisikospielen
regelmässig ihre Kollegen
aus Basel-Stadt.
Man postiert sich neben dem Stadion.
Dann heisst es: warten.
Nein, ich nehme es nicht ab.
Hinten noch etwas rauf.
Wir haben sehr häufig
lange Wartezeiten.
Ordnungsdienst heisst:
warten, um zu pressieren,
und pressieren, um zu warten.
Zurück im Heute -
an der Polizeischule in Hitzkirch.
Ein kurzes Einlaufen,
damit alle warm sind.
Alles weitere
sage ich währenddessen.
Rückwärts.
* Lautes Atmen *
Irgendwann wird auch
Jana Stierli zum Ordnungsdienst
für ein Fussballspiel
des FC Basel aufgeboten.
Und es kann
zu brenzligen Situationen kommen,
in denen Selbstverteidigung
wichtig wird.
Wenn er sich dagegen wehrt -
gerade er hat mehr Kraft als ich.
Wenn er seine Hände
nicht freigeben möchte,
bin ich gezwungen, das nicht mit
Kraft, sondern mit Technik zu lösen.
Techniken
können auch Schmerzpunkte sein.
Einige haben wir bereits gesehen.
unten am Kiefer:
reindrücken und rausziehen.
Unangenehm, oder?
Wir gehen nach hinten,
ans Ende des Kiefers.
Unterhalb des Ohrs:
reindrücken und gegen vorne drücken.
Sehr unangenehm.
Zentral ist, wo und wie lange
solche Techniken angewandt werden.
Priorität 1: nicht stürzen.
Das ist der Plan.
Wenn der Polizist am Boden liegt,
ist das sehr schlecht für ihn.
Wenn ihr zu zweit seid, helft ihr
dem Kollegen sofort, aufzustehen.
Wenn ihr alleine seid,
müsst ihr euch zu helfen wissen.
Das trainieren wir nun.
Gesäss auf den Boden ...
... und abrollen -
so schnell wie möglich.
Ziel ist, euch nicht auf Hände
und Ellenbogen abzustützen.
Oh, ja. Das nächste Mal muss ich
auf dem Boden bleiben.
Ich versuche es mal von hinten.
Nein.
Alles okay?
- Ja.
Okay.
Im Polizeiberuf lässt sich
nicht immer alles mit Worten lösen.
Manchmal kommt es zu Gewalt -
vielleicht irgendwann auch gegen sie.
Ich habe natürlich Respekt
bezüglich Sicherheit
im Arbeitsalltag.
Aber ich kann es
gar nicht beurteilen,
weil ich noch nie wirklich real ...
... den Polizeiberuf ausgeübt habe.
Bisher war es nur theoretisch.
Das ist komplett anders.
Zurück im Ordnungsdienst
vor der Coronapandemie.
Das Fussballspiel in Basel ist zu
Ende - und alles scheint friedlich.
Dann plötzlich ein Hinweis:
Die Zürcher Fans wollen ihren Zug
in Pratteln per Notbremse stoppen
und randalieren.
Auf dem Trottoir in Einerkolonne
Richtung Bahnhof.
Angespannte Minuten
am Bahnhof Pratteln.
* Pfiff *
(Mann) Aufsitzen.
Der Zug nach Zürich
fährt in Pratteln vorbei
und verlässt
den Kanton Basel-Landschaft.
Jetzt wird er zum Problem
der Aargauer
und später der Zürcher Kollegen.
Feierabend für Yves Chappuis.
Wir sind froh,
dass nichts passiert ist,
es keine Ausschreitungen und
v.a. keine Verletzten gegeben hat.
Wir können ruhigen Gewissens
nach Hause gehen.
Zurück in der Gegenwart in Hitzkirch.
Auslösen,
das Magazin hinunterschieben,
zwischen Ringfinger
und kleinem Finger.
Ich hole das neue Magazin, wieder
mit den Kriterien bei den Fingern.
Ich setze es ein, schiebe es hinauf.
Kontrollgriff.
Der Umgang mit der Dienstwaffe
beginnt mit Manipulationsübungen.
Laden und entladen - immer wieder.
Lieber langsam,
dafür technisch korrekt arbeiten.
Ganz einfach. Okay? Gut, laden.
Waffe laden.
Die Handgriffe sollen durch ständiges
Wiederholen zum Automatismus werden.
Die entsprechende Theorie hat
Jana Stierli längst verinnerlicht.
Ob ich im Notfall schiessen würde?
Ich denke, sicher.
Wichtig wäre aber,
vorher alle Möglichkeiten prüfen
und das Verhältnismässigkeitsprinzip
zu beachten.
Vom Schiesskeller
geht es ins Klassenzimmer.
Ihr seid mit sehr viel Macht
ausgestattet. Ihr wurdet rekrutiert.
Ihr seid die Auserwählten,
die nun Polizist/-in werden dürfen.
Sie müssen den Sachverhalt abklären,
den Sachverhalt erforschen
oder ermitteln.
Strassenverkehrsrecht:
Wo gilt es? Für wen gilt es?
Und wo steht es?
Die Menschenwürde ist der wichtigste
Grundbaustein der Bundesverfassung.
Ihnen wird
viel theoretisches Wissen vermittelt:
Berufsethik, Recht, Deutsch, Psycho-
logie, Kriminalistik und vieles mehr.
... muss fahrfähig sein
und, und, und.
(Frau)
Das gehört zu Ihren Aufträgen:
Sie müssen sich mit dem Gesetz,
v.a. dem Strafrecht, auskennen.
(Frau) Ich möchte es so sagen:
Wenn wir über Menschenrechte
und Berufsethik reden,
steht und fällt es
mit dem Thema Macht
und Verantwortung übernehmen.
Wir bereiten uns jetzt
auf den Ladendiebstahl vor,
der hier stattgefunden hat.
Wir werden gleich dorthin gerufen
und müssen die Situation bearbeiten.
Das machen wir heute zum ersten Mal.
Davor haben wir es
theoretisch angeschaut.
Heute haben wir erstmals
einen praktischen Fall.
Der Ladendetektiv
und die Filialleiterin sind vor Ort
und reden momentan mit dem Täter.
Verstanden. Wir fahren los.
In praktischen Übungen
müssen sie anfangen,
ihr theoretisches Wissen anzuwenden.
Die Rollen wechseln jeweils.
Der Baselbieter Nando Wüthrich
fängt als Polizist an,
ein Aargauer gibt den Ladendieb.
Haben Sie gesehen, wie der Diebstahl
stattgefunden hat?- Nein.
Der Ladendetektiv.
Sie sind Herr ...?- Holms.
Okay.
Der Instruktor beobachtet
und macht Notizen.
* Handy *
Können Sie das Handy
bitte ausschalten?
Ja?
Gerade etwas unpassend,
aber sprich nur.
Ja, ist gut.
Ich weiss es noch nicht ...
Entschuldigung. Können Sie bitte
das Handy ausschalten?
Lassen Sie ihn, ich habe es
im Griff. Ich kümmere mich darum.
Ich weiss auch nicht,
was das genau soll.
Können Sie bitte aufhören
zu telefonieren?
Sorry, ich muss aufhören.
Gut, danke schön.
Also ...
- (Frau) Gleich mitnehmen!
Ja, das sehen wir gleich.
Haben Sie meinen Namen mitbekommen?
Wüthrich
von der Kantonspolizei Basel-Land.
Ja, ist angeschrieben.
- Wer sind Sie?
Michael.
- Wie noch?
Genti.- Genti? Haben Sie eine ID
oder einen Führerausweis dabei?
N... Nein.
- Nicht?
Wie sind Sie
in dieser Situation gelandet?
Ich habe es dreimal erklärt:
All das hatte ich im Einkaufswagen.
Den Geldbeutel habe ich vergessen,
aber 10 Fr. hatte ich dabei.
Diese drei Dosen konnte ich kaufen,
den Rest liess ich im Rucksack.
Später hätte ich es bezahlt.
- Ah, später bezahlt.
D.h., sie hatten das im Rucksack
und verliessen den Laden?
Ja, aber ich kam nicht weit,
nur zwei Schritte.
Dann haben Sie ihn aufgefangen.
Gut, also, dann ... ähm ...
Ich möchte noch einmal sagen:
Ich wollte es nicht klauen.
Ich zahlte, was ich konnte, und
den Rest wollte ich später zahlen.
Das ist für mich kein Diebstahl.
- Möchten Sie noch etwas dazu sagen?
(Frau) Lügner.
- Das ist alles von meiner Seite.
Okay.
- Ich will, dass er bestraft wird.
Und für die Umtriebe
will ich auch etwas.
Ja.
Die Patrouille ist aufregend, oder?
Eigenwahrnehmung, bitte, ganz kurz.
Nando, gern.
- Ja, v.a. auch der Überblick.
Man kommt herein
und viele Leute stehen herum.
Wer ist wer? Bis man das weiss
und sich merken kann ...
Und wie nimmt man Kontakt auf?
Wie verhalten sich die Personen?
Wir wissen nicht, ob er lieb ist
oder nicht, ob er kooperativ ist.
Ja, es ist schwierig.
Was z.B. gefehlt hat:
Ich konnte die Dosen nehmen,
die ich dir
um die Ohren hätte hauen können.
Allgemein
wurde ich nicht kontrolliert:
Bin ich eine Gefahr oder nicht?
Und du hast mir einfach abgekauft,
dass ich den Ausweis
nicht dabei habe.
Hättest du
eine Grobkontrolle gemacht,
hättest du gemerkt,
dass ich doch einen habe.
Handythematik: unangenehm.
Du wirst merken: Mit der Zeit wirst
du mehr und stärker Einfluss nehmen.
Das geht gar nicht.
Hier läuft eine Sachverhaltsaufnahme
und sein Telefon klingelt.
Wie fremd ist denn das? Logisch
kann das passieren, aber abklemmen.
Sehr gut, vielen Dank.
Grundsätzlich bin ich sehr zufrieden
mit meiner Performance.
Es gibt halt Anfangsschwierigkeiten.
Es ist nicht so einfach, an alles
zu denken, die Routine fehlt noch.
Das Interessante ist: Man ist in
einer Situation und etwas passiert
oder jemand reagiert und dann merkt
man sofort: Das habe ich vergessen
oder das hätte ich
besser machen können.
Jetzt habe ich einen riesigen Kopf
mit Verbesserungsvorschlägen
und Gedanken,
wie ich es anders machen könnte.
Ich freue mich schon
aufs nächste Mal,
wenn wir
die nächste Möglichkeit haben,
das Ganze wieder anzuwenden,
um sich zu verbessern.
Jetzt gilt's ernst, richtig.
Die Manipulationsübungen sind vorbei.
Wir schiessen Kreis rechts,
drei Schuss ohne Zeitlimite.
Feuer frei.
Jetzt wird zum ersten Mal
scharf geschossen.
* Schüsse *
Du hast die Tendenz,
ein wenig nach oben zu gehen.
Je länger du zielst,
umso höher wirst du.
Hier dasselbe:
Die ersten drei waren super.
Dann hast du gewartet
und wurdest immer höher.
Das war auch gut. Aber du hast etwas
die Tendenz nach oben.
Gut, ihr müsst nicht kleben.
Kommt, 7 m.
* Kurzes Piepen *
Nicht schlecht, sagen wir es so. Es
ist okay, darf aber besser werden.
Ich habe das Gefühl, das ist im
Moment noch eine Schwäche von mir,
im Gegensatz zu anderen Dingen.
Aber "Übung macht den Meister",
sagt man ja so schön.
Und so geht es weiter:
Grüezi. Sie dürfen noch
das Licht einschalten.
Der Nachwuchs darf zum ersten Mal
mit auf Patrouille.
* Martinshorn *
Wir sind vor Ort.
Lass dich einfach nicht provozieren.
Niemand hat einen Gurt getragen.
Diese sind in ganz normalem Zustand.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
M. Gassner, E. Graf - 2021